hi I'm Michael Moynihan four reason TV
and today we are talking to Terry
Michael the head of the Washington
Center for politics and journalism the
boss the Grand Poobah Bazaar right
former press secretary for Paul Simon
and we are also with Mike Flynn the
director of government affairs at The
Reason Foundation and also an old hand
in Chicago politics who work for the way
you know don't don't
I'm just trying to think of the statute
of limitations in the state legislature
actually was a Republican Party the time
I worked there and there was one when I
left so I can vouch for what happened
afterwards for the Democrats in the
legislature in 1973 and we have two
experts on Chicago politics and
obviously there is a reason to discuss
Chicago politics again outside of Barack
Obama what is going on gentlemen with
with governor blog still a bit July stay
Levitch peter bogdanovich Blagojevich
whatever what's going on right now in
Chicago you know I have to say that I am
Not sure that this governor is really an
example of Illinois corruption I I think
there's some mental illness going on
there I think it's a sociopath but he
certainly comes out of the culture of
corruption that has been statewide not
just in Chicago well you have the Metro
East st. Louis area in Madison County
corruption you have deep Southern
Illinois law Cairo Cairo where the
Secretary of State in the late 1960s
Paul Powell when he died they found
$800,000 stuffed in shoeboxes in his
hotel room
you have Springfield the state
legislature which was corrupt my ex-boss
Paul Simon blew the whistle on that in a
Harper's Magazine article in 1963
corruption in the Illinois legislature
so you've got it everywhere Chicago
Springfield the legislature the Metro
East Center since 1963 I mean this is
something that runs very very deenis in
Chicago politics and doesn't seem to
have abated at all in the past 40 years
what really did a bate because it was a
lot of it was driven
by patronage and civil service sort of
got rid of some of that and that's why
the Secretary of State position has
always been the favored position
opposition the corrupt George Ryan he
was Secretary of State yeah you could
have all the jobs and jobs that can't do
as my patronage the you see George Ryan
who was in prison presidents in prison
but we should note that since Adlai
Stevenson was elected on a Reform ticket
in 1948 all the Democratic governors
elected since then have gone to jail and
now we're about to see a third would
probably go to jail
that would be Otto Kerner Dan Walker and
now governor log steal [ __ ] I do want
to say I mean I think a couple things
that actually changed in the time and
one is the corruptions a lot less petty
than it used to be you know before it
was you gave out a job as a sewer
inspector and maybe had a no-bid
contract now your stuff is just
underground or not real money yeah you
look even things like the bond offerings
of the state is incredibly corrupt and
you'll find you'll find sons and
daughters of legislators who work for
the bond agencies in Chicago who
suddenly get the business to issue the
bonds for the state you've got things
like the evident of state controlled
gaming licenses we're in the late 80s
early 90s some investors among
Republicans too could put up ten
thousand dollars to get a license that's
now worth 40 million yeah
the dollar amounts have gotten much
bigger so the scale of it has gotten
much bigger when you're working for
Republicans way back in the day there
was no big-ticket $1,000,000 items out
there you're saying they were just Marty
to me but it used to be like when I was
there and again I'm trying to think
statute of limitations I mean one of the
big things that you always had the
legislature every year was what was
called the pension bill and it was a
great big bipartisan everybody winking
this bill will go through and the bill
is stuffed with specific provisions for
individuals it was written in a way that
would never look like it was for
individuals but basically was letting
Moe on the northwest side have an extra
five years in his pension and that would
be a bill that would go through what I
saw when I was there is that people
always think of Chicago machine Democrat
politics Illinois being corrupt
it's fully a bipartisan industry at this
point and you have the top of the
Republican Party whom I can't name you
know is is just as deep into the
corruption is there something particular
to Chicago about this I mean we hear
this is there were constant meteor Fran
now is that well you know what do you
expect this is Chicago and we've known
about this for ages is is this something
that you find in other large cities
throughout America or is there something
particular to Chicago it's really all
about one party politics whenever you
have a one-party political system like
we're sitting one right now in the
District of Columbia where there's
nobody to keep an eye on the other guys
there's not a viable second party
therefore people get away with murder
and and that's exactly what happened
Chicago in became was a one-party
jurisdiction they controlled everything
there was no Republican Party to and you
know the press did a watchdog role but
you got to have another party to keep an
eye on the other guys and you also had a
real really well oiled machine that
still exists that was not blown apart by
racial politics gender politics things
that blew apart the machines in other
urban areas the Machine stayed in
Chicago and you've got the dailies
running the town for several decades the
thing that marked about Chicago unlike
say an urban area like Baltimore New
York is by many measures Chicago works
yeah it's a functioning City and so the
citizens in Chicago are feel okay
turning a blind eye to a lot of the
petty corruption because the city works
because trash is picked up because the
streets are plowed in the winter we're
in a lot of urban areas you don't have
that dynamic so basically what we have
right now is we have a story that is is
of national interest because of the
scale of corruption but clearly there's
another element here and the other
element is that Barack Obama's from
Chicago and you have a number of
Republicans foaming at the mouth trying
to tie Barack Obama to this scandal is
that going to happen is there any
indication right now that this will have
a negative effect on Brock Obama or even
Rahm Emanuel I I don't think so and this
is the point I want to make that
politics like life is about physics
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction the reaction in
- all that corruption was a really
healthy reform movement impactful Simon
helped lead that in the early 50s in
into the 60s there's almost a meme
stream that goes from Simon in that
reform movement to Brock Obama's brain
and I'll tell you how Dick Durbin was
Paul Simon's administrative assistant
when he was a lieutenant governor 69 to
72 Durbin kind of talked Obama into
running for president David Axelrod a
reporter as was I growing up knowing
about Paul Simon this mr. clean this
independent he was he's an Obama advisor
I will laughed when I saw the
Republicans during this past campaign
trying to tie Obama to the daily machine
he's from the completely different
tradition he's from the progressive
tradition from the reformed tradition in
politics that reacted to the corruption
and Illinois politics now let me say
there that certainly when you're in a
situation like that the reformers have
to work to some degree with the Machine
types if they want to get anything done
because they control the seats in the
legislature but Obama comes out of that
tradition I'm really amused by the Jesse
Jackson angle ah yes we have a limited
amount of time so let's finish on the
question about Jesse Jackson Jr who was
candidate number 5 contestant number 5
revealed and gave a sort of
mealy-mouthed press conference the other
day what's what's gonna happen - well
Jackson get on I spent 17 years as a
political communicator either he got the
worst advice but anyone's ever gotten
holding a press conference in which
almost Shakespearean protesteth too much
right way too much yeah you know you
gotta wonder what's going on there I
don't know no but his father's been
bulletproof he's also not part of the
daily machine okay and so be it explain
that a little bit he's is he's in sort
of an independent actor and yeah and the
real issue the drives are right now has
to do with airports oh because Jesse
Jackson is a big proponent of building
the third regional airport in Peotone
Illinois but that would remove all the
contracts in O'Hare they're controlled
by the city and Mayor Daley so he is
definitely out of the daily machine so I
expect him to be throwing the bus and
real quick I just went ahead and there's
one funny story about glue boy which is
I think is apocryphal for what happened
this week as a friend of mine reminded
me of it that he saw him in spring
not too long ago and well go ahead [ __ ]
like to brag quite often when he was a
Springfield about when he lived in DC
jogging through the streets he once ran
into Richard Nixon and he was so proud
of that and so I think of him being
arraigned before the judge in a jogging
suit being undone by tape conversations
I think you know he was foreshadowing
what was gonna happen to him later on
all right so we have determined today
that governor Blagojevich is royally
screwed Jesse Jackson will be thrown
under the bus and Barack Obama is going
to come out unscathed I think so all
right well thank you guys very much for
for coming down to talk to us Mike Flynn
of The Reason Foundation Thierry Michael
libertarian Democrat extraordinaire who
often publishes on the reason calm
website I'm Michael Moynihan for Reason
TV and thanks for watching